effectivement vous l'avez vu avengers
4.5 qui a été annoncé pour le 17 et 18
octobre à angers
bon je troll un petit peu et on n'en
joue un petit peu aussi mais vous
pourrez me retrouver à angers du coup
orange et geekfest le 17 et 18 octobre
donc ce week-end en compagnie du grand
héros cf on espère sincèrement voir
certains d'entre vous les planètes sont
alignées les timeline se croisent donc
c'est le moment est bien évidemment
toutes les infos sont en descriptions
bref on parle d' à 20h05
mais il est impossible de définir
exactement le film tout est repoussée
bref c'est très loin
une telle réunion a vraiment besoin
d'être préparée néanmoins pour définir
un tel événement on a besoin de gros
événements pour justement créé les
menaces et les problématiques du film
donc voilà sans prise de tête j'aimerais
juste qu'on parle du futur de marvel un
petit peu plus axé sur un cinquième opus
avengers en compagnie évidemment de
notre bon vieux heroes f bonjour et
merci pour l'invitation
[Musique]
quelque chose que je vous ai déjà
raconté plusieurs fois mais pour moi
captain marvel est une héroïne unique
dans le mc eu et qui va nous montrer de
belles intrigue
le personnage est beaucoup trop fort
physiquement et peut tout détruire tout
annihiler si elles le souhaitent
il ya vraiment un parallèle avec
superman est justement captain marvel a
beau être invincible physiquement le mc
une eau proposera forcément de nouvelles
menaces qui vont mettre en difficulté
carole des moeurs des menaces qui
agirait plus sur le côté mental ou
pourquoi pas politique
rentrons directement dans le vif du
sujet beaucoup de rumeurs tournent
autour de ce captain marvel 2 et
j'aimerais sincèrement vous proposer mes
idées déjà la guerre cris et scroll
captain marvel dans son premier film
après avoir découvert certaines vérités
et tout l'étendue de ses pouvoirs
décident de se rebeller face aux cris et
l'intelligent suprême ainsi que d'aidés
et sauver les skrull persécutés et c'est
là que c'est intéressant dans les comics
et c'est d'ailleurs comme ça que marvel
nous a tous berné pour le film les
skrull sont normalement considérés comme
des sortes antagonistes ces derniers
s'infiltre notamment sur la terre et
grâce à leur pouvoir de métamorphose et
usurpe l'identité des gens en prenant
leur apparence et bien que talent aussi
beaucoup de personnes de son peuple soit
bon et bien ce n'est pas le cas tout le
monde
ce que je veux dire c'est que la guerre
cris skrull est un conflit très complexe
un peuple n'est pas tout blanc ou tout
noir mais d'un gris très profond dont
klaus est pertinent c'est que carole va
devoir faire des choix compliqués car
effectivement décrit innocent il en
existe ainsi que des scroll malveillants
qui ont certainement déjà infiltré la
terre
comprenant déjà position du côté des
skrull par le biais de son premier film
et ce durant les années suivantes
l'image de carroll a été définie dans la
galaxie par exemple ceux qui détestent
les skrull pour diverses raisons
détesteront carole et pourrait même
vouloir l'attaqué mais serait ce une
raison pour carole de riposter et donc
perdre sa morale de justice hier est ce
que vous voyez l'idée carole ferait face
à une difficulté politique et la force
ne lui serait d'aucun recours
et au contraire beaucoup aimeraient
qu'elle soit leurs alliés pour justement
défaire leurs adversaires ça me rappelle
même run and l'accusateur qu'il a
désigné comme une arme et qu'il
reviendrait pour elle qui sait peut-être
même que les skrulls utilise carole
comme l'ont fait les cris ses traits
sociétal ce que je vous propose
le truc c'est que cette guerre crise
cruelle qui existe depuis toujours aura
forcément un impact sur les avengers
par exemple il est fort à parier que les
gardiens la galaxy seraient plus
méfiants décrit par rapport aux actions
de run and l'accusateur et ses alliés
comme korat al'inverse des héros
terriens pourraient se confronter aux
skrulls qui a envahi la planète est
usurpé l'identité de certains
personnages crayon donc le doute entre
les héros qui ne se ferait plus
confiance
d'ailleurs nous savons que miss marvel
arrivera très prochainement une héroïne
qui s'inspire de son idole
captain marvel tout comme pour rwanda
vision qui enchaînera avec doctor
strange 2 la série de miss marvel
enchaînera très certainement sur le
second opus de captain marvel depuis les
yeux de miss marvel nous pourrions voir
le début de la scission entre les héros
et la venue d'autres par le biais de
cette héroïne tout comme black panther
ou spider man à l'époque je verrais bien
un nova bref l'idée d'un nouveau film
civil war beaucoup plus orienté cosmique
est là où l'idée est plaisante c'est que
le premier civil war marque l'arrivée
la phase iii du mca et captain marvel 2
a été annoncé mais ne fait pas partie de
la phase 4
imaginez si le premier film de la phase
1 qui était donc ce captain marvel 2
avec une grande guerre opposant cris et
scrolls mais également les avengers
[Musique]
je souhaitais sincèrement vous parler
d'antoine car comme captain marvel ce
sont pour moi des personnages qui ont
énormément à proposer dans l'avenir du
mca et l'avantagent avec scott langue
c'est que c'est un mec lambda qui vit
sur la terre mais qui peut avoir accès à
des thématiques hyper complexe donc
marvel peut balancer sur lui et ce fut
le cas dans une game j'y ai toujours cru
en toman a son importance
et mon dieu qu'elle craque il a été dans
le film avec la solution du voyage dans
le temps maintenant si on ne revient à
antoine 3 le sujet est complexe car très
lointains et surtout extrêmement reliés
aux séries à venir
bon déjà par rapport à la thématique du
dans un prochain film avengers le champ
quantique
on connaît bien genre 1% de la chose
dans le mc il ya tellement de choses à
faire et tellement de choses à découvrir
tellement de nouvelles menaces également
par rapport à cet élément et par rapport
à ce lieu hors du temps et de l'espace
j'aimerais mettre une supposition qui
pour moi est établi depuis presque
toujours bon ok nous ne sommes qu'au
début des voyages dans le temps et à
travers les timeline
cependant le mcs se veut quand même plus
accessibles et simples que les comics
beaucoup de choses sont modifiées au
retravailler dans in game
le voyage dans le temps est possible
grâce au chant quantique et
accessoirement à travers les réalités
également sans exception comme la chaîne
du temps ou bien la gemme de l'espace
qui sont des artefacts presque divin ou
encore le cas du rwanda qui est un petit
peu particulier
et bien si quelqu'un de normal entre
guillemets souhaite manipuler le temps
et la réalité de manière normale
également on va dire le champ quantique
semble être la solution
et c'est là toute l'importance et la
pertinence dante man qui depuis la mort
de toni est le seul avec son groupe à
comprendre les ficelles du chant
quantique et de ses lois concernant le
voyage dans le temps l espace comme le
guardian sa réalité
antoine sera le premier au courant d'une
main
provenant du champ quantique vous voyez
ce que je veux dire maintenant à nous de
nous projeter dans le temps
la phase 4 nous a déjà été présenté et
antoine 3 n'en fait pas partie donc il
faudra prendre en compte ce que vont
nous apporter les oeuvres de cette
dernière notamment avec la série de
l'eau qui dans le trailer concernant
l'épopée de l'eau qui ce dernier semble
avoir trop joué avec la pierre de
l'espace ce qui lui vaudra de se faire
attraper par les autorités des
variations temporelles
on ne va pas aller trop dans les détails
mais c'est grossièrement parlant la
police du temps et de l'espace qui
veille à ce que ce ne soit pas trop le
bordel quoi et par rapport à ça nous
avons le célèbre antagonistes de quang
le conquérant un grand voyageur temporel
qui pourrait totalement rivaliser avec
thanos et donc qui a été en lien de
nombreuses fois avec cette police donc
voilà elle est là la problématique d'un
potentiel nouvel avengers
la série law qui permettrait
d'introduire ce nouvel antagoniste dans
une thématique beaucoup plus sombre et
cosmique que pour thanos on a clairement
levé loeb c'est l'heure des réalités et
du temps et comme je vous disais pour
antoine l'expert en chant quantique et
bien si kong arrive et agit dans la
réalité des avengers que nous
connaissons antoine le saura et le
découvrira très certainement après avoir
approfondi ses connaissances et ses
voyages en compagnie de la guêpe enquête
jeannette
enfin par rapport à un univers
simplifiée et cohérent et se pourrait
que cette police du temps et de l'espace
se trouve dans le champ quantique
symbolisant le micro verse par exemple
imaginez si antoine tombé dessus par
hasard
rencontrant gang et se faisant même jugé
pour ses actions dans une game
ouais bon j'avoue je pars un peu le mal
mais retenez bien le nom de gang
il se pourrait fortement que cette
antagonistes arrive prochainement
surtout qu'il est lié également aux
quatre fantastiques qui ne saurait
tarder à arriver aussi
[Musique]
quand on parle du dévoreur de mondes
j'ai toujours l'impression d'être dans
smash bros avec un sondage pour demander
aux fans qui ils veulent dans le jeu car
à chaque fois galactus fini dans le
peloton de tête tout le temps et en même
temps c'est tout à fait normal
on parle d'un très grand méchant de
marvel une divinité cosmique 13
ancestrale qui a besoin de se nourrir de
monde pour pouvoir survivre
un méchant bien plus dangereux que
thanos et qui correspond parfaitement au
level up de l'univers du mc eu et avec
des héros bien plus forts etc
mais en soi galactus il ya très peu de
nouvelles le concernant
et s'il doit apparaître ce serait bien
dans un avenger 5 et au minimum dans
plusieurs années pour bien prendre le
temps de créer la menace comme pour
thanos alors premièrement il se peut que
captain marvel 2 annonce la venue de
lettres cosmique
même s'il y a de belles choses à dire en
termes de théorie
j'essaie de toujours rester cohérent et
logique par rapport à l'univers et le
scénario si je vous dis captain marvel 2
c'est que l'on sait que le film sera
très important mais surtout je ne peux
m'empêcher de repenser à la scène post
générique de far from home cette scène
qui annonce très clairement le
développement du sport d' une
organisation qui comme pour le shield
traite des menaces extérieures à la
terre sauf qu'évidemment shield
signifiant bouclier sword & p
l'organisation est plus orientée dans l'
attaque
c'est pour ça qu'on retrouve nick fury
dans l'espace et comme je vous le disais
à l'époque
nick fury dans l'espace en compagnie des
scroll est en contact avec talent hausse
sur terre pas ça annonce obligatoirement
que captain marvel n'est pas loin mais
en termes de cohérence et de hype quoi
de mieux que nick fury pas un simple
humain pour faire la découverte de la
menace galactus une menace qu'on pourra
donc suivre à travers ses yeux
néanmoins comme première approche la
question des 4 fantastiques est
totalement légitime puisque galactus
possède ce qu'on appelle un héros une
sorte d' annonciateur de la venue de la
divine
afin de prévenir que la planète va
mourir le surfeur d'argent on est le
plus connu mais il ya aussi nova par
exemple la venue de ce héros pourrait
être le premier contact entre les
avengers et le dévoreur des mondes une
hype qui se créeraient dans l'ombre car
sans même voir galactus sa venue serait
annoncée mais moi ce qui m'interroge le
plus par rapport à la cohérence de
l'univers et du récit il faut que le
gala qu'ils soient présentés sous des
traits humains comme les tétanos
galactus est une divinité sans émotion
froid c'est pour ça que dans le film des
quatre fantastiques tout le conflit
émotionnelle était attribuée au surfeur
d'argent qui se retournera et se
sacrifiera pour tuer galactus qui est
symbolisé par un nuage une tempête
mais si dans le mc eu le dévoreur de
mondes doit devenir la prochaine star
des antagonistes il se doit alors
d'avoir des traits humains des émotions
des paroles et une certaine légitimité
il faut que le mc eu réussissent à
retransmettre la complexité du
personnage sans le dénaturer
comme je vous l'expliquais dans une
vidéo de aro galactus souffre et ne
mange pas des planètes par plaisir mais
pour sa survie
est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas une carte à
jouer là dessus pour finir dans la
cohérence galactus est plus puissant que
thanos et c'est là toute la
particularité si thanos a gagné contre
les avengers une fois est-ce qu'un
scénario montrant les avengers
vainqueur du premier coup face à
galactus ne décrédibiliserait pas
l'antagoniste est également en tant
qu'être cosmique ancestrale est ce qu'il
ne faudrait pas un objet pour le vaincre
je ne vois aucun héros pouvoir le battre
avec ces simples pouvoir et si c'était
le retour du gant de l'infini
c'est tout con hein mais comme pour
dormammu strange en est venu à bout
grâce à la pierre du temps sans cei ne
pouvait rien faire je vous le dis si on
penche vers un univers plus entre les
réalités
le temps nous sommes très loin d'en
avoir fini avec les pierres ah oui
d'ailleurs je m'en rappelle que
maintenant mais la venue de galactus
d'or fortnight c'est quand même une
énorme symbolique
tout comme il y avait thanos il ya
quelques temps marvel et 100% impliqué
dans la collaboration
donc c'est que cela avait été approuvé
et validé donc gros indices en
perspective un très grand merci à vous
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo et surtout
un énorme merci à heroes de m'avoir
accompagné sur cette vidéo
si vous ne le savez pas on fait
actuellement une double vidéo donc c'est
à dire qu'à heroes a lui aussi sorti une
vidéo dans laquelle j'apparais donc si
ça vous intéresse
resté jusqu'à la fin pour les
annotations cliquable bon sinon c'est un
petit peu particulier à la base je
voulais vous faire un trois théories
mais s'est passé je n'ai pas senti en
fait le truc c'est que je pouvais pas
vous proposer vraiment 1,3 théorie avec
des belles théories bien brut quoi parce
que tout simplement en fait y'a rien de
spécial qu'on sait sur à 20h05 en fait
y'a pas d'infos vraiment quoi mais je
souhaitais réellement parler et malgré
l'absence de la firme et où les
circonstances actuelles
j'avais vraiment envie de parler de
marvel et d'un peu relancé cette un exam
manqué un petit peu
enfin voila merci à tous n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner à laisser un petit
commentaire à me suivre sur les réseaux
sociaux et j'ai hâte de voir certains
d'entre vous à angers j'espère que
j'enverrai certains donc voilà allez
c'était un argot rock
ciao tout le monde et que le 'lion'
charte soit avec vous
[Musique]